輝達宣布追加了
1500億美元的
回購自家股票的授權
那這是美國企業史上
最大的一次
這次幹嘛又加這麼多
大家好歡迎再次收看
投資的一千零一夜
我是峰哥
輝達跟台積電
一個是美國最好的晶片公司
一個是台灣最強的晶圓代工
也是全世界最強
但為什麼
它們的股價
最近都漲不太動
它們業績很好
口袋很多錢
那些錢又花到哪裡
這是我們今天這一集
要討論的題目
我們先來看一個很重要的事情
就是9月28號這一天
我們在新聞上
看到有兩個很重要的事
一個是輝達宣布追加了
1500億美元的
回購自家股票的授權
那這是美國企業史上
最大的一次
回購授權的增加的金額
那直接又打破了
蘋果在2024年的
1100億美元的紀錄
那另外一個很重要的消息是
半導體
大家最重要的 關心的台積電說
傳出
這是傳出
說要在美國蓋第2個園區
那第二個園區落腳在
美國的達拉斯
這個呼聲現在是最高
預計是要蓋6座先進晶圓廠
總投資金額甚至估計會超過在
亞利桑那州鳳凰城的
2650億美元
所以這個
換算成新台幣就是一個
8.4兆新台幣的一個大數字
一家公司是把錢拿來買
自己的股票
另外一家是把錢拿去美國
蓋工廠
所以我們今天跟大家拆解是
這兩個決定
它們背後到底在盤算什麼
首先我們把這兩件事情
湊在一起
看似不相關
不過是同一個
AI浪潮的兩種花錢方式
我們來看輝達它是輕資產
錢太多
所以它用回購來回答市場
對AI泡沫
循環融資的質疑
這是過去一段時間以來
大家常常在挑戰的
就是你們是不是靠
自己的錢在循環
另外台積電是重資產
它的錢要花在蓋廠
所以它用德州新廠
這個新投資來回答
川普的關稅威脅
所以一個是跟華爾街講話
跟投資人講話
另外一個是跟華府講話
跟政治勢力講話
對投資人來說輝達的回購股票
是顯示它
口袋還有錢
而且是很多錢的底氣
那這個目標我覺得是
想要救一下股價
畢竟輝達的本益比
可以說是直直落
所以投資人就不禁發毛
是有什麼我不知道的壞事嗎
不然輝達本益比
為什麼一直往下掉
那台積電的德州廠就比較像是
因應地緣政治風險的保險費
再加碼
這確實有可能會
壓低台積電的毛利率
但換來的是
未來長期在美國市場的通行證
以及可以避開
沒完沒了的關稅威脅
那我們再來看
輝達這1500億美元
回購自家股票
這個金額到底有多大
我們來看1500億美元
這個是史上最大增額
追加後
剩餘可回購額度
因為之前它回購了一次
但這個金額還沒買完
所以兩次加起來
有2350億美元
預計執行完畢的時間
會到2028年的
會計年度結束
那2027年會計年度
事實上就大部分發生在
2026年的日曆年
所以已經執行了大概
398億美元
那最近一個會計年度的
自由現金流
輝達有將近1000億美元
很驚人
口袋真的很深
可是市場更預估
它2028年的會計年度的
自由現金流會來到
3290億美元
這是一個更驚人的數字
所以輝達真的很有錢
那我們大家要注意一個細節
就是前面剛才講到
輝達今年就2次
大幅的加碼
回購自家股票
5月18號加碼800億美元
這一次又加碼1500億美元
也就是說5月28號那次
都還沒買完
這次幹嘛又加這麼多
你可以等到買完再加
為什麼要急著又加
所以我們來把
輝達這幾年的回購授權
都排一下就知道
很驚人
你看2024年的8月
500億美元
2025年的8月
600億美元
2026年的5月
800億美元
到了2026年9月
居然已經來到了
1500億美元
所以這個
幾乎每年都有
而且速度還愈來愈快
我們光看這一次的
1500億美元
這個金額來講
不要講說兩次
增加加起來有多少
光1500億美元
這個金額就大於
大概84%的
S&P 500成分股的
企業的市值
也就是說大概有84%的
這個成分股的市值都沒有高過
1500億美元
所以這個金額之大
你大概就可以想像
那輝達為什麼要這麼做
我覺得至少有3層盤算
第1層真的口袋錢真的太多了
而且它又不需要蓋工廠
因為輝達是IC設計公司
晶圓是靠這個
台積電在蓋廠在燒錢
所以輝達賺來的錢
它不需要大量的投入廠房設備
所以它最近一個會計年度的
自由現金流
就將近1000億美元
那我們剛才前面講到
市場預估2年後還可能變成
3290億美元
這個錢與其放在帳上
不如還給股東
可以刺激一下
低迷的股價
因為我們來看輝達今年到
9月28號為止
它的股價上漲
大約是22%多左右
可是跟競爭對手
AMD Intel比起來
真的是遜色不少
因為你知道AMD
上漲了183%
Intel更是
漲幅來到了214%
所以輝達的22%
看起來就是一個很遜色的表現
那第2層主要是回應
循環融資的質疑
這是我覺得最關鍵的一點
因為在今年7月底的時候
市場就爆出說輝達正在洽談
大概是2500億美元的
融資擔保要協助OpenAI
去承租俄亥俄州的資料中心
那根據彭博統計
輝達今年以來宣布了
類似這樣的交易就超過了
5400億美元
所以市場的疑慮很簡單
就是輝達它把錢
投資給客戶
客戶又拿輝達
投資它們的錢來買輝達晶片
那這個買晶片的需求
是真的需求還是自己養出來的
就是我們所謂的循環的融資
所以雖然黃仁勳9月在
高盛的科技大會上面
正面回應說輝達成長的上限
是來自於供應面的問題
而不是需求面的問題
不過嘴巴說就不如真金白銀
拿出來給大家看
所以1500億美元的
回購就是在告訴市場
如果你認為我的錢
都是左手換右手
那我哪裡來這麼多的錢
可以買回自己的股票
所以這是一個
他一個信念的一個表達
就是他自己
真的很有錢的表達
那第3層就是它可以抵銷
員工股票造成的稀釋
來撐住每股盈餘
因為科技公司每年會發
大量的股票給員工
特別是這幾年
因為績效非常好
所以你就會必須發
更多的股票給員工
所以股數會持續的膨脹
透過回購可以把這些
膨脹的股數買回來
讓每股盈餘
不會被稀釋得太嚴重
那這是一個比較
技術面的理由
可是長期的股東
真的很喜歡你這麼做
我們知道
股東看到公司回購
通常絕大多數都是很正面的
不過我們也來講一下
它的風險
回購固然是好事
代表公司有錢
代表公司對自己的未來有信心
可是我要提醒大家
如果一家還在高速成長的公司
它卻在推動
大規模的回購
某種程度代表它目前
找不到更好的地方去投資
像蘋果在2024年
那一次
它1100億美元的回購
建構在的背景是
手機成長已經大幅放緩
甚至手機都可能有一點
要面臨衰退
那輝達就不一樣
它明明還在高速成長
公司還預估2028年
會計年度的營收
還要再成長約70%
所以這一次就比較像
我賺太多了也到處投資了
像台灣的聯發科都得到了好處
得到輝達將近
35億美元的投資
可是就是還有剩錢
不過投資人要記得
回購的授權不一定會買完
就像我們前面講的
它上一次的授權都還沒有買完
所以
它只是一個上限
你真正要追蹤的是
它最後真的買了多少
而這些錢
實際對市場的
產生的刺激的效果
又有多少
接下來我們來看的是台積電
它的德州第2園區
目前還是傳聞
當然我相信大家因為會
繼續追這個消息
而且既然會傳出這個消息
也不可能完全都是
沒有一點根據
不過台積電並沒有
正式的證實這件事情
所以大家還是要先確認
台積電並沒有
正式的講過這句話
但是這個傳聞有它的邏輯
我們可以來看數字
因為以現在來比較
亞利桑那州
2650億美元
那德州傳聞
應該會超過這個金額
那規畫的內容
前面我們講過
亞利桑那州
6座晶圓廠
2座先進封裝跟1座研發中心
那德州傳聞是6座的
先進晶圓廠
製程當然
後發的會更先進
那為什麼
在德州的達拉斯會有吸引力
那當地稱為叫矽草原
包括德儀 包括三星
包括Coherent
包括特斯拉
其實都已經在那裡設廠了
從半導體 光通訊
國防軍工的聚落
其實已經形成了
那台積電的供應商
環球晶也在達拉斯北邊
謝爾曼市
蓋全美最大的
12吋的矽晶圓生產廠
那台積電在那邊
生產邏輯上
應該有4個盤算
那第1層主要當然就是
客戶就在美國
因為從2026年的
上半年的統計
台積電的營收大概
有差不多75%
是來自美國客戶
輝達 蘋果 超微 英特爾
全部都要求在美國製造
當然也不是它們
堅持在美國製造
而是美國政府要求它們
提高在美國製造比例
所以它們被迫
一定要在美國製造
那客戶在哪裡
工廠就要跟到哪裡
這是一個鐵律
那過去是因為實在是
在美國生產成本太高了
但現在受到政治壓力
你就幾乎是沒得選了
那第2層就是關稅保險
那這是最核心的一個原因
因為9月9號
川普又在達拉斯的造勢場合上
點名台灣說
台灣晶片要賣到美國
要付100% 要付200%
現在幾乎是關稅課多少呢
就是川普突然想到什麼
他就說什麼
所以到底會不會變成政策
你也不知道
可是那個威脅總是在
但我們要確定的就是說
這個所謂的100% 200%
都不是馬上要實施的政策
目前真的實際會生效的
是今年1月15號
根據232條款
對特定的高效能運算晶片
要加徵25%的關稅
至於第2階段
怎麼擴大呢
現在只是一個說法
並沒有真正的定案
不過這裡面還有一個關鍵機制
就是說根據台美的協議
如果台廠赴美投資
所產生的這個
產能的效益
最高可以得到
2.5倍的免稅配額
所以這個意思就是說
如果你在美國的投資愈多
你實際生產出來的產能愈大
能夠得到
免關稅的進口的配額的額度
就愈大
所以德州第2個園區
它不只是為了要蓋
一個能夠生產的工廠
而是在買一個
關稅保險就是
亞利桑那州買完了
現在在買在德州
因為你也不可能
過度的集中在亞利桑那州
因為亞利桑那州
現在現實的問題
它同樣有水電跟人才的問題
特別是人才的問題
是一個很大的瓶頸
那第3層就是台灣自己的
水電的供給能力
確實也很有限
因為先進製程
確實非常
吃水電的供應
所以你把這個
未來一部分產能
放到美國
也是在分散台灣這邊的
這個供給的壓力
那第4層分散地緣政治風險
就不用特別講
這個現在大家都知道
從美國的政府到美國的客戶
現在也都很擔心
地緣政治風險
愈來愈升高
所以供應鏈不希望
全部集中在台灣生產
所以台積電去
美國蓋廠我們知道
最大的代價就是毛利率
那台積電過去
在法說會上也提過
海外廠會稀釋毛利率
這也大家都知道
全台灣投資人
應該沒有人
不知道這個道理
但是毛利率
下降這件事
畢竟是一個可管控的風險
這個代價
值得付也應該要付得起
因為如果不去而你要面對的
是關稅風險
以及潛在的
地緣政治風險
那這個真的就是很難管控
而且風險
可能變得非常高
而且你如果想想
現在美國如果未來
整個政黨競爭關係
美國兩黨的政府
都競相飆車要求
台積電要提供更多
所以這就變成一個潛在
難以預測的風險
所造成的傷害會遠遠大於
毛利率降幾個百分點的
這個風險
一句話來總結
我們前面講的論點就是輝達
它是用錢來證明
自己不是泡沫
台積電是用錢來證明
自己不會被關稅擋在
美國市場的門外
接下來我們談股價的影響
就做這些事之後
對輝達跟對台積電的股價
影響是什麼
我們先來看輝達
那截至9月28號
輝達股價是
228.86美元
那如果用過去的12個月獲利
來計算也就是所謂的
落後本益比算出來大概是
28.5倍
可是如果你用市場預估的
輝達未來的獲利
去算前瞻本益比
這個數字甚至降到只有
18倍到19倍
如果你把這個數字
放到輝達的股價歷史來看
你會覺得
那真是非常便宜
因為過去在多頭時期的階段
輝達本益比常常可以達到
50倍以上
甚至到70 80倍都有
那一家營收還在高速成長
AI晶片市占率是居於
市場領先地位的公司
前瞻本益比居然不到20倍
這說真的不太像
典型的高成長
科技股的估值
輝達本益比下跌
主要原因
並不是因為股價跌
而是它EPS上升的速度
遠快過股價
但這又很矛盾
因為傳統上
大多數的成長股的股價漲幅
都會強過
EPS的增幅
所以現在這種奇怪現象
就是所謂的本益比壓縮
也就是市場擔心
輝達現在的預估EPS
到底能不能實現
AI產業帳面的獲利
到底是虛幻的還是真實的
這也就刺激輝達這麼做
就之前回購還沒買完
再加碼就是因為知道
現在市場缺的不是帳面EPS
而是信心
它用這一招是希望
買回投資人的信心
所以我覺得這麼做
一定會有激勵股價的成效
但這個效果也沒有達到會讓它
大漲的程度
因為目前市場擔心的並不是
輝達的口袋有多深
而是整個AI鏈的口袋
還有沒有錢
接下來看台積電的股價
我們也用本益比來看台積電
上半年EPS49.32元
這是公司財報
那如果你加上第3 第4季的
這個法人的預估
我們來看一下高盛的預估
2026年的全年
高盛預估大概差不多是
109元的EPS
所以我們如果換算成
本益比18倍是1962元
本益比21倍是2289元
本益比24倍是2616元
那如果到2027會計年度
高盛預估的EPS來到
140元左右
那本益比18倍是2520元
本益比21倍2940元
本益比24倍就會來到了
3360元
所以如果我們用9月29號
台積電收盤價
2475元來計算大概就是
目前的本益比只有22.7倍
那明年的獲利來算
就真的連18倍都不到
這時候就真的很委屈了
因為台股指數
已經創新高了
但台積電股價沒創新高
所以股價這麼委屈到底為什麼
我們去找別的原因
因為看起來不是基本面的原因
那是不是籌碼面的原因
所以如果我們去分析籌碼
我們會發現
台積電這段盤整
橫盤
沒辦法創新高的階段
其實外資整體來看
其實是沒有什麼賣超的
就是買買賣賣
但是賣超並不大
反而是內資縮手了
不管是從投信的買賣超
或從融資餘額的變化
你都可以看出來內資追價
台積電現在的意願
沒有過去1年多那麼強
甚至我們可以這麼推論
最近幾年
外資其實是持續賣出台積電的
因為外資在台積電的持股
最高曾經達到78%以上
那本土資金
反而是持續買進的
目前外資持有台積電
已經降到
70%以下
並且在這裡
開始碰到瓶頸就是
外資賣出的這個水位
本土資金的買盤
沒有像過去那麼大
變慢了
而台積電的市值就太大
就導致股價推不太動
所以我們可以看到
台股的市場上
那些萬金股
甚至5000 6000元
7000 8000元的
股票還在衝
可是台積電就不動如山
所以總結來看
AI這場仗還沒打完
但是已經從比技術到了比口袋
跟比未來布局的階段
所以
短線看資金
長線看發展
即使輝達跟台積電最近的股價
表現平平
可能很多人也滿失望的
不過它們的長期的投資價值
跟長期發展
目前來看還是相當正面
只是說實現這個價值的過程
變慢了
變久了
你需要更有耐心
以上就是今天分享
喜歡我們節目歡迎幫我們
按讚訂閱分享以及開啟小鈴鐺
謝謝大家